Okay. So here's the quiz. Michael is going to answer it, but we
want to give you a chance to answer it first. I've got these
two equations of two different hydroplanes,
though they're parallel to one another,
'because they have the same parameters. That is to say, I have two
equations and two unknowns. I want to subtract them from one another
and what we want you to do is we want you to
solve for the line that is described by their difference. Do you
understand that, Michael? Or, have I, have I told them enough, or not?
>> Yeah, I
think I'm just going to subtract the second equation
from the first equation. It seems pretty straightforward.
>> Okay, it seems reasonable to me. But remember, the
output that I want you to figure out here is
exactly what the distances between those two planes, okay?
That is, between what's represented by X1 and X2, okay? Go.